Sam starts off this hour in Atlanta
Georgia hi Sam how are you very well
days thank you how are you better than I
deserve what's up so how can you tell
whether or not a charity is properly run
and/or corrupt the server example is
there any way to tell how much of the
donations are receives actually go
towards the cause of support depending
on the size of the charity they will
have detailed financial statements that
will reveal that and if they're
unwilling to make their financials
public I don't give to them okay so that
generally be on their website
yeah or you can just you know you can
you can poke around on a little bit and
find it but for instance several years
ago there was a big controversy that the
guy running the United Way was making a
million a year mmm right that's one out
that kind of thing and so what we look
for with the Ramsey Family Foundation my
daughter runs that Denise and we always
do investigations in detail in how the
ministry or how the charity is run what
it does obviously we don't give to
ministries or charities that borrow
money
since we don't borrow money they'll be
kind of stupid and so we don't do that
as an example we look at that we talk to
them we interview them and we don't
spend an inordinate amount of time if
we're giving $10 to somebody but if
you're if we're given fifty or a hundred
thousand bucks to somebody then we
really need to look at that that's a big
investment of God's money into something
and so we we look at it just like we
were buying a company or like we were
investing in a company if you're going
to put you know substantial money into
one then you would read the more you're
going to put it the more you'd look into
it the more due diligence you would do
but financials are pretty readily
available and that they also oftentimes
will print a ratio of what percentage
goes to expenses and how much actually
goes to you know the cause in question
and and if it is in the ministry world
there's some certifications of the
financial statements and so forth that
you can look for too
and you know just look at that and
that'll help you as well so again the
smaller and more primitive that the
charity is the more in question
you got it the more you got to look at
that stuff and but somebody like the
United Way or Red Cross or a big
ministry organization like Samaritan's
Purse or something it's a no-brainer you
can look at it and you can find it all
in about five minutes and you can see
what the ratios are it is very
reasonable for a charity to have some
administrative expenses but you don't
want 90% of the money given to go to the
administrative expenses and only 10%
going to the starving children you know
if you want to do that we just give some
money to the starving children directly
be a lot more efficient so because
they're not very efficient with that but
some administrative expense is very
reasonable and very normal and you know
that that's because they're on the
ground they're boots on the ground doing
whatever it is that that particular
group does but yeah and I'll just tell
you again the ratio is the more money
you're going to give to that particular
charity or ministry the more time you
spend investigating so a small gift we
don't spend any time on you know to give
somebody five hundred bucks or something
we wouldn't we wouldn't spend you know
we'll spend two thousand dollars worth
of your time trying to figure out where
to give five hundred dollars that just
gets weird
so but you would do that you know again
the larger the gift the more in-depth we
research the people that are involved
the process that they use for the
ministry the ratio of administrative
cost versus actual lift or gift or to
the you know the people we're trying to
help with the thing and and you know
business practices how well they operate
how operationally efficient they are and
clean and they are and that kind of
thing we're looking at all of that in
this process because we look at it as we
are investing God's money and we need to
be able to look at him and go hey we
checked it out we made a good investment
just you know what's been a whole bunch
of time doing due diligence on your own
investments but not on God's investments
that would be weird too so uh sometimes
we get sloppy with charitable giving and
your
questions are very very good one the
that none of us need to be hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]